la comisión europea ha abierto un
expediente contra las leyes de hungría y
polonia que consideran que discriminan a
la comunidad lgtb y en el caso de
hungría la comisión europea rechaza que
a partir de ahora en las escuelas no se
pueda hablar de sexualidad tampoco se
podrán emitir películas y series de
televisión en el horario infantil en que
aparezcan parejas del mismo sexo y
además relaciona de forma velada
pedofilia con homosexualidad
si el gobierno húngaro mantiene esta ley
el caso podría acabar en la justicia
europea aunque esta polémica ley ha
provocado muchísimo rechazo también
entre los diferentes países de la unión
europea en la última reunión de jefes de
estado de gobierno la gran mayoría de
líderes europeos mostraron su rechazo al
primer ministro del país viktor orbán en
el caso de polonia algunos municipios
del país se han declarado zonas libres
de personas lgtb y lo que puede provocar
una clara discriminación por la
orientación sexual de las personas
hungría y polonia mantienen un pulso
desde hace muchos años con la unión
europea por algunos
los que vulneran el estado de derecho
pero hasta ahora apenas ha habido
consecuencias